[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TURNTABLE SCRATCHING]
What up, y'all?
This is DJ Rob Swift, straight
from New York City, Queens,
here in the streets of
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
having fun at MIT.
[TURNTABLE SCRATCHING]
MIT invited
me to teach a two week workshop
on six fundamental scratches.
The foundation of all
scratch techniques.
A lot of these techniques
took months, years to develop
and the students that
took this class were just
so excited and motivated
that they learned everything
in a day.
And over the course
of the workshop,
they just practiced to
master the techniques.
I myself, in general, have
just devoted my life's work
to teaching the art of DJing
to anyone that wants to learn.
MIT being a progressive
school that it
has provided this
opportunity for me
to teach the students
here about DJing,
and not just the techniques
involved, you know,
moving a record back and forth,
but the culture and the history
behind it.
You can go on YouTube and watch
a quick five minute tutorial
but not have context on how rich
the history is behind this art
form.
And I'm just super
grateful and glad that we
get to bring something
like this to MIT.
[TURNTABLE SCRATCHING]